про исландию Ну до этого времени я
ничего не знала Кроме того что это край
Земли формировался из вулкана это весь
материк Ну не знаю я думала что здесь
очень очень очень очень холодно на самом
деле очень немного знают про исландию я
вам больше скажу я сначала подписался на
путешествие а потом через месяц зашёл в
интернете и посмотрел где вообще
находится Исландия это такая особенная
Земля здесь овеяно всякими преданиями
легендами здесь были всякие мифические
существа жили там тролли
гномы Маги как я думаю правда это или
нет И если это сейчас ну я думаю что
Конечно правда Поэтому я
[музыка]
здесь Какая наша цель на эти 8 дней
максимально эффективно провести 8 дней
получив глубокие знания полезные
знакомства и яркие впечатления на всю
жизнь три вещи Поэтому постарайтесь
оставить того человека который загружен
которые в заботах ве в проблемах
оставить там далеко в стране а здесь вы
другие путешественник никогда не
возвращается домой уезжает один человек
приезжает Другой у нас ещё будет игра
называется Тайный друг ваша задача в
течение всех этих дней всячески ему
помогать так помочь чтобы этот человек
не смог догадаться что это я это как
волшебство вот те же самые мы но мы сами
себе создаём чудеса и заботу тот Тайный
друг который оказал больше всего
различных услуг помощи и так далее И при
этом остался незамеченным от нас получит
отдельный приз поэтому очень важно
оказаться
[музыка]
неразгаданный Я из любимого города
Алматы но сейчас живу в Батуми в Грузии
штат Калифорния Соединённые Штаты
Америки я из Ташкента из Узбекистана Я
занимаюсь автомобильны бизнесом У нас
два автосалона в городе Москва у меня
Строительная сфера занимаюсь
недвижимостью в частности это участки
Если вы когда-нибудь получали букеты
цветов то значит мы менялись энергиями и
наша упаковка была в ваших
[музыка]
руках Я люблю пешие прогулки туризм
люблю путешествовать заниматься спортом
конкретно бегом велосипедом мечтать Я
люблю знакоми
люлю у и это ВС
[музыка]
здесь а я приехала сюда чтобы пообщаться
конечно с марм кам Ну познакомиться с
новыми людьми Открыть новые направления
в бизнесе Возможно у кого-то перенять
какой-то опыт Ну и какой-то покой найти
нано
яю насладиться природой Здесь очень
красиво я уверена что это путешествие
изменит мою
[аплодисменты]
жизнь каждый раз когда мы выбираем
локацию куда нам ехать Я прежде всего
смотрю по Бакет листу Дело в том что у
меня есть Бакет лист Бакет лист - это
список моих желаний или мест которые я
хочу посетить при этой жизни после того
как мы определили локацию Куда поедем мы
определяем сезон и И после этого мы уже
начинаем определять местные
достопримечательности вокруг этой
основной локации поэтому выбор
путешествие или место путешествия - это
совсем не случайное действие и не
спонтанное действие и не так что мы
исходим из того что вот я сейчас хочу
или это сейчас модно Нет это на самом
деле самые значимые места нашей планеты
Земля
[музыка]
Мы видели там дельфины очень красивые э
волны энергию
людей которые стояли впереди которые
были постоянно
облитые это вообще супер Я побоялась
идти Это было просто незабываемо сидеть
на носу этого катера и когда тебя просто
захлёб эту воду это воло
незыгарь
Хотя познакомились Вчера я обожаю воду
воды в Исландии много и я думаю Надеюсь
даже и я знаю что будет
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
рафтинг сейчас
едем куда-то в горы на склад Мы едем на
рафтинг на источник едем тотально
промокать
[музыка]
был опыт в рафтинг но как бы такой было
экстремально я думаю сейчас тоже будет
непросто Главное чтобы лёд не попадался
под Вёсла Я капец боюсь воды и плавать и
вообще Ра Первый раз я боюсь я немножко
боюсь в холодную воду ехать но я думаю
мы справимся и всё будет супер
[музыка]
Tears patience Won't stop Till Great
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
это это прям Круто правда мне бы ещё
парочку Таких вот этих
сди нибудь
горами классно Круто правда мне очень
понравилось особенно когда Сергей читал
нам стихи с этой природой А даже если
вода была очень холодная но было так
тепло и
душевно это очень э такой адреналин был
э холодно
замёрзли первые 2 минуты было холодно
потом чуть-чуть ноги мёрз а потом уже а
не знаю то ли привыкло тело А и всё было
супер А когда вот в горячую воду зашли
такое ощущение было как будто бы мы вот
прям мурашками так иголками копнули А
ему что в речке Офигенно 6° что здесь 36
тоже
офигенно после холода тёпленький вода
Вообще кайф
шикарно понравилась команда в наше лодки
понравилось то что было их семь человек
и я одна и они все за меня переживали Я
не знаю от того что ты знаешь что рядом
с тобой люди которые тебя если что
спасут и как-то так становилось тепло и
[музыка]
дружно чувство страха Оно всегда
присутствует в каждом из нас особенно в
нас предпринимателей по Поэтому вот
такие поездки они очень крутые они на
самом деле вытаскивают с тебя все эмоции
становишься новым человеком это крутые
ощущения словами все не передать поэтому
Ребята это очень
круто в процессе нашего тревел майда я
обычно даю ученикам много контента
который состоит из трёх основных блоков
первый блок я рассказываю про свои
концепции своё видение мира то как я
понимаю это очень важно Для того чтобы
люди вошли в контекст что вы понимали со
мной многие вещи и я во время дачи
контента объясняю очень много значений
терминов концепций определений понятий и
так далее дальше У меня идёт блок
вопросов ответов Это для того чтобы люди
чётко усвоили что им Я дал в контентной
части и третий блок мы переходим ко
сборам учеников когда люди смотрят Как
применяются вот эти концепции и знания
которые я им дал Как применяются на
практике Как они помогают людям
принимать решения и выходить из
различных затруднительных ситуаций Что
такое критический фактор контроля вот я
могу сказать Саша нали мне чай Это один
вариант Саша может налить может не
налить я второй заход го Саша Налей
пожалуйста чай са может налить может не
налить третий вариант я говорю Саш Налей
пожалуйста чай я тебе 100 долларов дам я
всё время повышаю ставки и увеличиваю
вероятность того что са наны чай тоже
самое вы делаете в бизнесе со своими
сотрудниками Я подойду к Саше возьму его
за одно место и скажу быстро мне налил
чай он мне нальёт чай независимо от того
каким тоном я это говорю вот это то за
что я заплатил называется критический
фактор контроля когда я увидел марна
ковалевича на так скажем видео и когда я
слышал вживую две разные вещи когда
смотришь по инстаграму или по Ютубу ты
понимаешь у тебя информация до мозга
доходит А здесь доходит прямо до сердца
и это конечно вообще сносит
голову не только у меня у всех
участников и это подходит всем и это
очень круто всегда это заканчивается
трансформацией учеников потому что
ученики приезжают сюда с определёнными
запросами и в процессе разборов и в
процессе объяснения концепции и в
процессе вопросов и ответов они сами
находят ответы на свои вопросы если они
это не находят то мы берём такого
ученика делаем разборы и в процессе
разборов он получает мнение всех
участников групп о том как они бы
поступили бы на его месте Ну естественно
с моими комментариями Ну а теперь нужно
развеять свой голову и проехать вновь по
этим красивым
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
местам вообще сегодня самый классный
день который у нас есть по программе
потому что
здесь водопад за который можно зайти и
рный пляж с
бушующим но очень притягательным здесь и
водопад сфо на который можно подняться
самый быстро Тающий ледник Исландии соль
мык вот Скоро пойдём когда я вообще
приземлился ощущение было Как будто я на
Марс приземлился
совсем-совсем
другой
см где я живу да И тут достаточно
времени побыть самому собой а понять что
есть Что с тобой Что с твоим будущим Как
правильно в нём надо развиваться и
конечно правильно можно вот тут именно
посидеть и подумать о своей миссии
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
а
[музыка]
в Исландии Фантастическая природа это
вулканы ледники чёрные вулканические
пляжи это водопады фьорды это киты это я
не знаю такой природы вы не видели нигде
на нашей
планете сейчас Мы прибыли в локацию
называется Голубая лагуна Фишка в том
что она находится вокруг неё лава и вот
мы смотрим сейчас все и Сланцы и туристы
с кайфом здесь отдыхают тем более нам
сегодня просто сказочно повезло сегодня
шикарная погода мы сейчас будем как на
лучших курортах побережья морей Да
отдыхать солнышком и кайфовать в горячей
горячих
[музыка]
источниках понял почему здесь вода
голубая потому что там есть ещё и
Зелёная маска и вот она превра
растворяется и превращается в голубую
лагуну они не правы это не чёрная и не
белая это молодильная маска белая она
омолаживает на 15 лет чёрная на 5 лет
Зелёная на 10 лет поэтому
это сначала мажешь чёрной ждёшь потом
смываю 3 минуты по-моему
чёрный потом белый я не помню сколько я
сразу смыл и сейчас вот зелёненькое
намажем Вам разрешают это магическое
зелье нанести на себя всего лишь на 10
минут знаете почему Потому что
скидываешь сразу 10 лет если ты особо не
машинисты Вот как вот этот парень
который снимает то это очень опасно для
вас очень опасно начнут на баре сейчас
просить паспорт поэтому
подумай Ну мне это было нужно реально
как бы мне уже в городе уже намекали что
пора те в исланди вот такой бассейн пото
что с коже явно есть проблемы Но вот
наконец-то я решил эту проблему и всё
будет хорошо Теперь буду на 20 лет
моложе выглядеть Да классная по что она
такая ещё голубая и ну по приколу
настроени Атмосфера классная голубая
[музыка]
[смех]
Лагода мы сечас направляемся прекрасный
самый длинный в мире рукотворный туннель
который сделан Рите Да он самый большой
самый длинный там будет холодно и очень
красиво Я думаю что будет круто а если
Никита снимет для нас классные кадры то
будет вообще всё прекрасно
[музыка]
у
У каждого есть Тайный друг и мы должны
для этого человека что-то сделать
приятное но чтобы он не заметил и не
узнал мне подарили букет цветов сегодня
было я решил сегодня поспать чуть
подольше только в 8:30 прям сильно
постучались в мои дверь я проснулся
такой злой открывая дверь смотрю никого
нет вижу только вдалеке там уборщица
стоит
сме поставил мне у двери коробочку с
чак-чак и убежал внимание где-то место
займу где-то на тренировку с утра тащат
но я ни раз так и не
пошёл это зуб кита Да ё прикиньте
Спасибо Тайный друг не знаю это от
тайного друга или не от друга все были
добры ко мне и давили разные вещи
поэтому мне тяжело понять кто мой йг
где-то были носки где-то были яблоки
шоколадки
могу предположить что это
АБ У меня есть подозрение вот на Виктора
почему-то потому что он постоя постоянно
где-то рядом тодай
зарядку то вышли мне аудио то ещё
что-нибудь Тайный друг настолько
незаметно всё делал что я ни разу не
почувствовал ничего и не
заметил до вчерашнего вечера был один
претендент но когда без ме
Нет у меня больше
друзей почему-то я думаю что это
Александр
[музыка]
вот очень много контента были разборы
участникам очень понравилось Я уверен
Вот это поездка повлияет на их жизнь
кардинально поэтому мы заканчиваем это
Путешествие с чувством выполненного
долга с вдохновением мотивацией и
энергией для совершения новых под и
достижения новых успехов Открывайте
новые тропы Открывайте не туристические
места И самое главное путешествуйте со
смыслом каждое путешествие должно быть
началом Вашей новой жизни
H heur Hallo He H heur
[музыка]
Go
это было круто это была самая лучшая
поездка в мире самое лучшее путешествие
самый лучший полёт я бы сказал что это
одна из лучших поез которой я когда-либо
был назвать это просто поездкой Это ни о
чём на самом деле это очень крутая
поездка и Я очень благодарен что я
принял Это правильное решение и приехал
сюда Это путешествие поменяло всю мою
жизнь и я жду не дождусь когда вернусь
нового